we stand with Israel and we will make
sure Israel has what it needs to take
care of its citizens defend itself and
respond to this attack we're surging
additional military assistance we're
going to make sure that Israel does not
run out of these critical assets
President Biden is well-meaning but he's
absolutely wrong to send even more
military aid to Israel Hamas attacks
over the weekend were horrific
terrorists Gunn down hundreds of men
women and children in their cars and in
their homes it was brutal and US
politicians should absolutely condemn
the violence but Israel has received
more than 260 billion doll from the US
since its founding which is more than
any other Nation there's little reason
to think providing even more money and
weapons to the government of Israel will
help create peaceful living conditions
in the region the bottom line is that
the US government shouldn't send
American tax dollars overseas to pay for
other countries defense budgets and
getting more involved in conflicts
around the globe hasn't made the US any
safer